si j'emploie yale en ce qui vous
concerne tous les deux je vais dire ya
les beaux il ya les belles où il ya les
boel ça c'est top un problème compliqué
qui est la question de l'accord des
adjectifs
qu'à l'oral et compliqué à la il ya
différents types de pratiques et à des
personnes qui alterne le masculin et le
féminin dans les dents les accords dans
les phrases et à l'écrit il ya la
possibilité de mettre un point médian
donc dans la halle dans le langage là où
il pourrait avoir sa place c'est pour ça
que c'est donc un parent série mentation
que ces questions de gens là sont une
expérimentation qui sont en cours et il
n'y a pas de vala de règles arrêtées sur
comment faire c'est ça émergent des
personnes qui les utilisent après je
voudrais juste revenir sur la question
du jeu du neutre du genre nezan fin de
l'utilisation du prénom il du pronom il
est des mots masculin pour désigner des
cas généraux qui pourrait inclure du
féminin et du masculin on est vraiment
pour moi dans une neutralité dans une
source neutralité dans une neutralité
qui est colorée pour le dire comme ça
coloré du masculin en fait et quand on
est une petite fille quand on est une
femme quand on est une jeune femme on a
force d'entendre un discours général
même à l'école sur les métiers par
exemple à force d'entendre un politique
un force d'entendre le journaliste on
voit bien que on ne peut pas se projeter
dans ces existences là dans ces métiers
là dans ces professions là donc il ya
vraiment comme un impact du langage sur
les représentations et sur sa propre
place dans la société
[Musique]